i gotta give we gotta give an honorable
mention to ian for this next segment the
guardian reports kiev is furious as eu
wavers on banning russia from the swift
payment system now before we get into
everything i just want to point this out
if you guys
you know there's a lot of people they're
like oh world war iii it's clickbait
it's not going to happen
the swift payment system it's the
international monetary international
banking system ach payments bank
transfers it's how trade is done
if russia gets booted because this is
what's happening kiev is furious they
say we want it to happen but there are
members of eu like germany they're
saying we don't want to do it boris
johnson is saying do it boot russia from
swift this would mean russia can't use
banks anymore outside of the country it
cuts them off financially do you think
china says sorry russia can't help you
or do you think china says we'll
facilitate the trade for you do you
think russia says oh no i guess we've
lost and now everything is done or do
you think russia says you want a war
we'll give you one cutting them off from
the financial system
look
the only thing it will do
is push russia further away and give
them less of a reason to actually
negotiate on any of this stuff
and i see blue checks i see high profile
democrat personalities and and never
trump or neocon types being like yeah we
should do this yeah yeah shut it down
and i'm like okay give russia nothing
left to lose do it and then see how they
respond fortunately i'm from the
washington examiner 50 minutes ago biden
declines to cut russia from swift
payments no no that's from today's
sanctions there's going to be a meeting
i believe tomorrow so biden today
said we're only going to sanction some
of their biggest banks we we are not
going to be cutting them off from swift
this does not mean they won't in the
future
still sounds like a baby step to me
right saying your four largest banks are
being cut off it's saying
be prepared we're gonna we're gonna shut
down your entire financial system coming
so crazy and then you see him shutting
off the bank accounts of the canadian
people the uh celinski the president of
ukraine has shut off three according to
tulsi gabbard three of the largest
television stations in prison like this
is western democracy doing these things
shutting up threatening to shut off
economies
we're not the good guys no no no maybe
we're not the good guys war war war
ain't no thing no nobody's a good guy or
is not a walk in the park during world
war two we had an office of censorship
the u.s had a department oh it was
either it was a department of censorship
who slipped synchronization the germans
had the minister of propaganda goebbels
yo we had internment camps for the
japanese in the united states
the this idea don't teach that too often
anymore no they they they browse right
over that in in you know u.s history one
and two in high school now they don't
know what they're doing tournament camps
yeah they're not for me well now i mean
you know these days yeah i mean history
history class has gotten watered down
tremendously since you know since the
time that we were in school we should
know more i mean that's that's something
that's really important because again
it's it's if we are going to be the
country that says
you are wrong
you can't do this we need to start
working on
our
best and like tim was saying in war you
know things how things change maybe
there was some value to in turning the
japanese that may have been japanese
spies who knows if we hadn't in turn the
japanese that was that was the initial
overthrow that was the initial uh
reasoning for it but it was like
japanese citizens civilians like expats
people that didn't deserve to be
imprisoned were being in turn so there's
a lot of collateral damage when you do
something as sweeping as that so you you
talk a lot ian about the swift payment
system
tell me your ideas on the swift payment
system it's like a global i don't know
who created it or where exactly i
imagine it has to do with the bank of
international settlements in switzerland
but it's like a company it actually goes
through the bank of belgium wow like i
think like 11 000 banks
all right 11 000 banks 200 countries
around the world
and it moves through the bank of belgium
the society for worldwide interbank
financial telecommunication
swift it was founded in 1973 48 years
ago
la holt does that you pronounce it
belgium
it handles basically uh all
i'm sorry it says uh
around half of all high-value
cross-border payments worldwide use the
swift network does it have any figure as
to the dollar amount of the transactions
that go through that type of it says 30
i'm sure it's staggering 32 million
messages per day
so
a transaction i i would imagine a
million okay so that's
you're talking an unconceivable amount
of money probably and it's probably dark
money too i bet a lot of that's under
the table that's the problem with the
bank of international settlements in
switzerland where they kind of funnel
money through is there's no oversight no
governmental oversight in the world it's
a private company that's controlling
this
economy basically right now so i have i
have a
maybe maybe you'll have some thoughts on
this right so
say we do
kick them out
right we kick them out of swift
where does the crypto market come into
that oh baby they'll probably make like
a bomb today yeah they'll probably make
it their national currency a crypto
they'll probably create like one or or
use bitcoin or or that's an interesting
what what happens with the crypto market
then when when an entire country says
all right you'll kick me off of you know
your your traditional standard
um you know transaction system well
we have crypto that's right and
you can't shut that down you can't
russia can just very easily say
we're going to now unless you shut off
their their internet in the entire
country i guess would be the that was
the threat
that's the threat and again look how
quickly that escalates you know that
you could you could replace you could
replace the banking ledger with the
crypto ledger
you could say here's how we're going to
do i mean i'm sure russia's already
working on it russia's bought up bitcoin
they're probably saying why should we
rely on the centralized controlled
payment system out of out of out of
western europe
we can just use decentralized crypto to
facilitate value exchanges and then have
that be the basis for our monetary
system in our own country and again you
have
talking from a crypto standpoint you
know i i have a a very novice level of
understanding of crypto but okay they
say okay we're going to adopt crypto and
then what happens when the entire
russian economy switches to mining
crypto they have the space for it they
have the resources
you know they could do it up in those
really cold siberian places where it
keeps the gpus colder we're in an
interesting place in crypto where we're
moving away from proof of work to create
the crypto and it's moving towards proof
of stake so like the people that are
rich are going to get more rich but the
people that are creating it are not
really going to be the ones that make
money on it anymore it's kind of it's
kind of lame that they're doing that but
it's like a rich man well it's what
happens when government gets starts
getting involved in these things you
know crypto was at least from my
understanding the uh the the separation
between government oversight and
regulation and money and now we're
watching governments
adopt it
when i when i saw we're going to pro we
may provoke in one of the world's
largest countries to adopt them it may
be inevitable actually i wonder if that
i was thinking the bastion of freedom
united states that's now invaded and
enslaved iraqis for 20 years it would be
the the pressure that would push a
country to
develop some sort of more free equitable
currency when when i saw the news
about you know ukraine saying we want
them banned from from swift uh uh kiev
saying we want to ban from swift when i
saw boris johnson saying it i
immediately bought bitcoin immediately
that's just me i'm not giving anybody
advice i bought it and then right after
i did i was in the dip because it
dropped when the chaos happened and then
spiked again and i was in the dip and it
spiked and i was like all right that's
good for me i guess but you know what
i'm thinking
if they do ban look they're already
sanctioning these banks these banks can
already circumvent that by using bitcoin
right now yeah so what is that saying
sanctions are meaningless
but if they kick him off swift i think
bitcoin through the roof
because russia is going to be like buy
it up and what does china do at that
point buy it up oh yeah after after
they've already taken this hard stance
against you know kind of crypto and that
you can trust
i guess they've taken a hard stance
against people owning crypto but they
i'm sure they have no problem buying it
up themselves no they're they they do
that as a game they they they put out
these bans so they can strike the price
down because people panic and they can
buy it back up
you know what might happen i don't know
if it will we kick russia off swift
russia says we're gonna use bitcoin to
back our transactions and handle our
international trade china says hey
russia we're in it with you we want your
help on taiwan both russia and china
don't like the petro dollar anyway they
say okay you don't want to trade oil you
don't want us to get access to your
markets we're going to cut you off from
our energy production and we're going to
buy in crypto or bitcoin or other
currencies you can't do nothing about it
at this point it could precipitate the
end of the of the us dollar
absolutely at a
i mean we're we're watching it like
slowly kind of like just decline at this
point but that would that would be an
over
night
just
death to the dollar not to mention gas
prices already skyrocketing what are
they saying four bucks a gallon is
coming yeah because now we're getting
close now with the sanctions of the
conflict russia is going to be pushing
back being like you don't get our oil if
we can't trade on your systems we don't
we don't give you the oil we're going to
keep it for ourselves and i bet you joe
biden doesn't even consider opening our
national pipelines oh no he's shutting
him down there was a he recently
recently there was news um i should try
i'll try and find in a second recently
issued a ban on on producing natural gas
in the united states another one why
i don't know man a little swedish girl
why why
no no why is that green guilt it's green
guilt why are they taking the idea cbp
from our southern border to go to
poland the policy is it is to gut this
country either because they're morons or
they're laughing all the way down
it's got to be i believe the latter i
really i really do at this point you
can't be
you know you hear people all the time oh
joe budden he's so stupid and you know
come on i i don't believe these people
are that stupid you don't get to that
position in life being an idiot
he's good at following orders that's for
sure
sure
but
you can't be making this many mistakes
they've made too many mistakes at this
point for it to be stupidity yeah i
think you're you're gutting this country
from the inside i think corporations
including the federal like the oh we're
units just take it one issue at a time
look at the southern border and work
your way up from there what comes across
the southern border illegals you know
people
nobody vetted fentanyl the number one
killer of the ages between what 18 and
35 right now is fentanyl where does that
come from comes from china you know look
at our supply chain look at our energy
production look at the value of our
dollar all of these things are moving in
the wrong direction and they're they are
all the result of policy created by our
own government these aren't none of
these things are happening to us because
of outside influence i wonder if yeah
sure china is shipping drugs but we have
a responsibility to protect our own
border we're not doing any of these
things and all of the problems that
we're facing today as a as a society as
an american society are self-inflicted
by our own government moving moving
border agents to poland when we have a
clear
crisis at the border is about the
stupidest thing i've ever heard thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there is a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there
you